على كل حال اليوم عيون السياح لها نظره
مختلفه عن عيون اهل البلد لتفاصيله فما
ابرز ملفتك في السعوديه كفرنسي قادم الى
السعوديه اولا
السعوديه همم هي مرات الرحمن هي بلد
السعاده هي بلاد الامان وانا
السعوديه
والشعب السعوديه اللطيف جدا
الترحيب الترحيب قويه جدا همم مثلا مثلا
عندما
اقول السلام عليكم واهلا وسهلا الى شخص
سعودي
[موسيقى]
سلامهم همم دلاله الدلاله على الحميميه
همم
انت لا تتقن فقط اللغه ولا تتحدثها بطلاقه
فقط ولكن تحرس على التزام بالتقاليد
السعوديه والعدد السعوديه وحتى الظهور
بالزي التقليدي كمان نشاهدك اليوم ونشاهدك
على مواقع التواصل من خلال فيديوهاتك ليش
تح ازيك يا ابويا
طيب انا انا اعتقد السعوديه يجوز الهويه
انا فرنسي اصلي من كل اجدادي 100% ولكن
انا اتحدث اللغه العربيه لانني احب
السعوديه عشان اكتشفت اهل السعوديه في
السعوديه والحين انا ادرس اللغه الفرنسيه
الى الطلاب السعوديين وانا فخور فخوره جدا
وايضا انا عندي خلاص مثلا عندما البس الزي
السعودي انا انا اعتبره ذلك كما اخلاص
الاخلاص في الكلام وقوه الكلام
وهذا الشباب
الاقل
تمثول جدا
ويشرفني كثيرا مثلا عندما اراء السعوديين
يلبس البداله الفرنسيه في فرنسا
وانا اريد السعوديون لديهم نفس السعاده
ونفس الشرف عندما يراني بالزي السعودي